foreign
[Music]
briefing for Tuesday March 28th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
has this ever happened to you
you're looking for something to eat on a
delivery app and you come across several
restaurants that all appear to be
different but all seem to have exactly
the same food
well on Tuesday ubereats is set to
announce it's doing something about this
it plans to take down about 5 000 online
only menus that represent about 10
percent of listings on the app in the US
and Canada with me to discuss how things
came to this point is our restaurant
reporter Heather Hadden hi Heather
thanks for joining us thanks so much so
to start off when we talk about multiple
listings from one restaurant are these
ghost kitchens some of them can be but
often these are actually from real
restaurants with a physical address and
an actual door these are online only
brands that a lot of restaurants started
during the pandemic as a way to shore up
their businesses and dine in seating was
closed and it's basically run out of an
existing kitchen it could be a ghost
kitchen but it's often an actual
physical restaurant where they're
offering what's supposed to be a unique
menu out of that restaurant for online
app orders can you tell us a little bit
more of about why restaurants would
choose to do this to have multiple
listings maybe give us some examples of
restaurants that are doing it yeah so
again during the pandemic when dining
rooms closed a lot of Brands including
established Brands like casual dining
restaurants like Chili's or Denny's or
Ihop decided that they needed additional
Revenue to keep themselves afloat so at
a restaurant like IHOP or Denny's often
their kitchens are pretty slow in the
evening even though they're 24-hour
Concepts and so they added these new
unique brands that are serving burgers
or grilled cheese or quesadillas to
appeal to Consumers many of them younger
than their typical demographic to order
through apps and to have it delivered to
them so they're using their kitchens
often they're using existing ingredients
in their restaurants but advertising and
marketing it in a new way and offering a
a new and distinctive menu so
Uber has made this
this to kick off around five thousand
online
restaurants from its
app so Uber and you know a lot of the
apps say this as well that things just
got really overheated amongst these
virtual Brands all these menus will come
up and some of them are just the same
menu under different names and emerging
out of the same restaurant or for the
same overall company and there's really
no differentiation between them and so
you know these apps say thousands of
these have mushroomed and ubereats is
taking
very definitive action to clean up what
they say has become a wild wild west out
there of these virtual brands that they
say that they need to call some of these
just so their customers can really trust
what they're ordering is an actual
distinct restaurant with its own
you know own food and own menu as
opposed to a copycat is there
or real estates
these virtual Brands might be take over
yeah I mean search is huge I mean how
you engineer search is a whole art these
days and
there's outside third party services
that will help you and your search on
these apps how customers actually
discover your brand you can pay
Consultants to make that even better you
want to be on top you want to be towards
the top so when someone is hungry and
scrolling you show up apart from just
kicking off many of these online brands
are there any other rules that ubereats
is bringing in yeah so in addition to
making sure the menus are distinctive
ubereats is also going to require that
online Brands list photos of five items
that are unique to its menu ubereats
will also take down virtual restaurants
whose average ratings drop Beyond a
certain threshold and that's kind of
similar to some what some of the other
companies are starting to do we talked
to GrubHub who said it's also making
sure that there's not too many Brands
stemming from one same physical address
and making sure that orders and
cancellation rates aren't too high from
particular virtual
restaurant before they would sanction
them you spoke with users of the app
what did they say about this phenomenon
yeah I think for going online you know
maybe it's also like online shopping
these days it can just feel kind of
overwhelming there's just so many
listings you don't really know where
it's coming from the National Restaurant
Association actually did a survey and
the majority of customers say they want
to have food delivered from an actual
place they want to know that there's
some Integrity to the listing into the
restaurant before they're eating the
food so I think you know there's been
some comedians that have spoofed this
phenomenon but I think for the regular
customer they just want to know what
they're getting is is real all right
that was our reporter Heather Hadden
thanks for joining us Heather thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing but a quick note on AI before
we close the show we still want to hear
your questions about generative
artificial intelligence AI programs like
chat GPT Microsoft's new Bing search or
Google's Bard and we're going to answer
them on an upcoming episode do you want
to know more about how these AI programs
work what they're capable of or maybe
what this latest wave of AI development
could mean for how we live our lives
leave us a voicemail with your AI
question at
415-439-6482 or email us a voice
recording to tnv wsj.com we look forward
to hearing from you I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening foreign
[Music]